these textile machines would normally be
operating at full capacity but the Greek
clothing industry has been hit hard
during 10 days of bank closures lack of
cash has made it difficult for
manufacturers to import fabrics this
Factory is only producing from two of
its 10 machines Lord all due to the
recession in the market in the last two
weeks production had to stop no one's
producing no one's buying everyone
scared so many companies have given
holidays to the workers while waiting to
see what happens later on Wednesday
Greek Prime Minister Alexis tsipras met
with opposition leaders in Athens
tsipras said he wanted to brief all
political parties who supported his
fellow clan militias Hoagland giving
those the prime minister appeared
confident as he returned to Athens
earlier in the evening siii press
visited the president to update him on
the latest from Strasbourg earlier in
the day he received both accolades and
criticism at the EU Parliament as a man
elna keep it easy what we call the Greek
crisis is the manifestation of the
inability of the eurozone to find a
lasting solution Samia after photo too
many Krrish Krrish Krrish back in Greece
workers at this close factory are still
producing but they are not show for how
much longer before the bank closes they
exported to 25 countries but they can't
pay suppliers abroad whether that
situation changes is down to Alexis
tsipras he has until midnight to come up
with a new reform plan